Speaker 1: . All right, so as most of you
probably noticed while I was gone, Donald
Trump wasn't reinstated.
Joe Biden is still the president.
Michael Dell was wrong.
Q, You know, whatever.
Z why they were all wrong.
OK, you guys get it.
Trump is not going to be reinstated.
The Department of Homeland Security is now
actually increasingly worried about the demands
for violence they're starting to see from
Trump circles if Donald Trump is not reinstated.
Now, of course, you and I know Trump is not
going to be reinstated.
And so that's very, very concerning.
There's a good Rolling Stone article, which
we're going to look at by Peter Wade called
Die Hard. Trump supporters increasingly demand
violence if he isn't reinstated.
Homeland Security warns the Department of
Homeland Security issued a warning.
Believers in the false conspiracy theory that
Trump will be reinstated have increased their
calls for violence if the former president
isn't back in the White House soon.
Some conspiracy theories associated with reinstating
former President Trump have included calls
for violence if desired outcomes are not realized,
the DHS bulletin obtained by ABC News said.
The bulletin went on to say that the recent
increase in public visibility of liars like
the My Pillow guy, Michael and Del, by the
way, check out his interview with me from
a couple of weeks ago is the reason for the
uptick in violent online chatter?
Lyndell continues to relentlessly push the
big lie that the election was stolen, going
so far as to say that he expects the Supreme
Court to unanimously rule in favor of reinstating
Trump as president in August.
That's a delusional belief.
Over the last few days, what has occurred
is there's been much more public visibility,
meaning the discussions and these theories
have migrated away from being contained within
the conspiracy extremist online communities
to where they're being the topic of discussion
on web forums or more public web forums, even
within the sort of media ecosystem.
That's according to a senior DHS official.
The drunken Trump crowd has been triggered
so much that Homeland Security says they're
concerned about the calls for violence increasing
further.
We have been concerned about the exact same
thing going on to say.
Does this bulletin?
As public visibility of the narrative's increases,
we're concerned about more calls to violence.
Past circumstances have illustrated that calls
for violence could expand rapidly in the public
domain and may be occurring outside of publicly
available channels.
As such, lone offenders and small groups of
individuals could mobilize to violence with
little to no warning, the DHS added.
Although they do not have specifics of an
imminent threat, their reporting indicates
the timing for these activities may occur
during August.
Although we lack information on specific plots
or planned actions.
So there's a few different things here.
Number one, Donald Trump is going back to
the rallies this Saturday, this Saturday,
in fact, a.
I'm debating, I'll tell you, it's like this
stuff is so base, but I'll tell you so there's
Trump's doing a rally in Alabama this Saturday,
8:00 p.m. Eastern, 7:00 p.m. Central.
I'll be streaming it.
There are some who believe that at this rally,
Donald Trump is going to call for another
insurrection and that all hell is going to
break loose.
That's one hypothesis.
The other idea that's been floated is that
at the rally Saturday, Trump will be reinstated,
that it'll be in Alabama because it's a good
southern state, I guess.
Who the hell knows?
And Trump will be reinstated on Saturday.
And there are fears that when he is obviously
not reinstated Saturday, that some of the
followers will take the violence immediately.
I don't know what the hell is going on.
So that's one piece of it and that's part
of the relevance of this this particular week.
Secondly, how lowbrow is it to have Trump
as a hero?
Like, you know, it's this is very coarse,
right?
It's not this is not deep politics, but the
bizarre hair and the strange tan and the idiocy.
He doesn't know anything about history or
economics or politics, hasn't read a book
in his adult life.
He's a billionaire, but he can't even even
get suits that look even reasonably OK, like
he's just an embarrassing mess of a person.
And you really have to understand cults to
understand what's going on.
It's it's the Jim Jones stuff.
I go back to the People's Temple Road to Jonestown,
check out Jeff Gwynn's book.
It's a fantastic it's instructive history,
really, about how these cult leader types
end up with the followers that they have.
So DHS is worried.
We've been worried.
And let's hope that nothing like this happens
this weekend.